hey david donald trump famously said he
could shoot people on fifth avenue
and not lose any support what would it
take
for trump's base to abandon him so i've
said before
would trump's base abandon him if he
insulted them
if he said my base is filled with just
trash
losers i'd never be caught dead with i
still think even in that case a lot of
trump voters would say
he wasn't insulting me he met somebody
else
he didn't mean me when he talked about
his supporters that he hates
i still don't think that attacking his
own base
would get a large number of trump
supporters to abandon him
however i do believe there are people
who would abandon trump if he loudly
came out
in favor of women's right to choose
an abortion if it's right for them
donald trump has
maintained this absurd unbelievable lie
that even though he was pro-choice his
entire life
until he was 68 years old that when he
was in his late 60s
he met a kid and he liked the kid and
the kid's mom said you know
i thought about having an abortion but i
decided not to
trump claims that was an awakening
moment for him
where he said i've got to be against
abortion it's an obvious lie
trump clearly is pro-choice it wouldn't
be shocking to me if trump has paid for
abortions for some of his mistresses it
wouldn't surprise me
i do think that there's a part of
trump's base the evangelical voters
where if trump said hey you know what
this right to life stuff
the march for life that i spoke at no
i'm pro-choice
i do think a lot of those uh
anti-abortion
voters would abandon donald trump but
the reality is
um it's not a huge part of trump's base
evangelicals aren't really his base
they came to him after mostly supporting
i think it was ted cruz
and others in 2016 they went to trump
when the options were trump or hillary
and they certainly
weren't going to be voting for hillary
clinton i really don't know
what it would take for trump's real base
to abandon him i
i actually think they would be in denial
no matter what
and they would support him if trump came
out and was loudly anti-gun
maybe some of his base would abandon him
but even then
trump has said some relatively
anti-gun things but then he'll come back
and say joe biden will cancel the second
amendment and it's
kind of like a choose your own adventure
i like this thing trump said so i'm
going to believe that that's his real
position
i really can't think of anything trump
could do
to get the bulk of his real base
to abandon him i want to hear from you
is there something he could do
am i on to something with the gun idea
is baby the abortion
issue bigger for more of his base than
just the evangelicals that i'm conceding
let me know what you think we've got a
great bonus show for you today
the bonus show is available to all of
our
members and all of our patrons
contributing at the five dollar a month
level okay
go to joinpakman.com we have a coupon
code
2020 now it'll save you 66
grab a membership you'll get instant
access to the bonus show
or make a pledge over at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow and you will also get
instant access
otherwise that's it for this week i'll
see you next week and remember not only
five new shows next week
not only five new bonus shows next week
tuesday night
september 29th 8 30 pm eastern time
5 30 p.m pacific the first debate
between donald trump and joe biden we
will be live
on youtube twitch and facebook i hope to
see you there